[Aplausos]
eu vou contar hoje pra vocês um pouco da
minha história e como é que eu dei um
passo para me afastar de um incômodo que
sentia sempre que me deparado de alguma
forma com algum tipo de competição
eu não sei que vocês sentem sobre a
competição
mas eu vou entrar nesse assunto agora
isso aqui é o que eu faço eu trabalho
com design de informações com um
pensamento visual com facilitação
gráfica é e eu comecei bem pequenininha
a desenhar eu sempre tive essa coisa do
visual bem forte
eu desenhava com o meu pai observava a
minha mãe a arquiteta e quando eu era
adolescente eu era aquela pessoa que
sempre usava flecha as cores pelas
minhas bordas do caderno sempre tinham
vários esquemas vários desenhos e eu fui
me desenvolvendo fui caminhando nesse
lugar e hoje eu faço eu registro
conteúdo de palestras e simpósios de
aulas ea minha empresa ela foi a segunda
de são paulo em 2010
a gente teve um convite para desenvolver
um para passar esse conteúdo para mais
gente pra gente dar um workshop para dar
aula e desde então desde 2010 a gente
tem feito duas três vezes por ano
segundo shop e centenas de pessoas
passaram por nós desde então e foi um
momento muito legal da nossa história
porque vários alunos nossos eles
começaram a trabalhar nesta área fazer
colheita gráfica também trabalhar com
facilitação gráfica e eles é ea gente
estava como se abrindo uma nova um novo
campo no brasil né e esses alunos eles
foram se desenvolvendo eles foram
desenvolvendo práticas inovadoras e era
muito estimulante a gente estava super
bem a gente tinha vários clientes a
gente interage
antes até um dia que eu comecei a achar
um pouco estranho porque eu recebi um
pedido numa proposta e quando eu mandei
minha proposta o cliente ele negociou
ele negociou e ele falou que tinha um
dos profissionais que estavam cobrando
mais barato e aí comecei a ver que a
gente estava participando de
concorrências ea coisa estava ficando um
pouquinho diferente do que era antes
eu me sentia super bem feliz né porque
meus alunos estavam bem ea gente estava
fazendo trabalhos muito bacanas mas ao
mesmo tempo eu me sentia às vezes
angustiada eu sentia um pouco
desconfiada do que estava acontecendo e
aconteceu que eu comecei a ficar confuso
porque de um lado tinha uma voz que me
falava não está percebendo que você está
formando seus competidores
só que ao mesmo tempo uma outra voz
falava pra mim continua você tem que
continuar formando tem que continuar
apresentando essa ferramenta para mais
gente porque é uma nova forma de se
comunicar é uma forma não tão racional e
muita gente começou com esse novo jeito
de se comunicar inclusive adolescentes
inclusive crianças então continua
e aí toda vez que eu marcava o workshop
meus irmãos sabem bem eu entrava num
conflito e ficava será que eu paro
de fazer seu uso na taça no shopping não
vou fazer um workshop nenhum eu vou
ficar com essa ferramenta só pra mim vou
ganhar bastante dinheiro ficar super
rica e aí a outra voz vinha falar e eu
acabava sempre escolhendo o caminho do
coletivo e acabava dando assim um
workshop e continuando até hoje o
shopping
meus alunos meus queridos alunos
eu sentia um super carinho por eles eu
não queria nada não queria saber de nada
deles que pudesse causar qualquer
conflito então esses meus alunos meus
competidores é eu até parentes seguir
vários no nas redes sociais porque eu
não queria nenhuma informação que tirar
essa minha estabilidade né
então eu decidi ir comigo mesmo que eu
ia caminhar só na luz ia ficar sem saber
de nada
saber quem queria ver nada só que um dia
eu estava navegando é e eu me deparei
com um post lindo de um aluno que eu
tinha esquecido de parar de seguir
e aí eu cair de cara no chão e aí vários
sentimentos eles começaram a emergir
sentimentos represadas era angústia era
inveja eu tô falando de mim né eu sei
que aqui quase ninguém sente nenhum tipo
de sentimento estranho quando vê alguma
pessoa trabalha na mesma área
e aí eu olhava para aquele sentimento de
forma acintosa não é possível esse
sentimento são muito estranhos é over
para essa situação essa situação onde eu
tô me deparei com um post um aluno
estudar aqui está esquisito e aí eu
resolvi investigar
geralmente quando a gente se prepara com
sentimentos estranhos a gente se distrai
a gente vai ver televisão e vai ver o
futebol vai falar com o filho vai
cozinhar mas neste momento eu resolvi ir
para o quarto apague as luzes quando
querem distrair com coisas que eu tava
vendo eu fiquei lá no escuro com aquele
sentimento dentro de mim e aí como uma
corda vermelha eles começaram a trazer
outros sentimentos ea coisa começou a se
intensificar
e aí a coisa começou a ficar mais
raivosa mais conflituoso e eu deixando
aquela coisa vira de repente o que
aconteceu foi que tudo se transformou
numa grande tristeza e era uma tristeza
profunda tristeza antiga dessa tristeza
eu comecei a ver imagens começaram a
ouvir várias imagens na minha mente
imagens de uma vila pequena no meio
manila sozinha que estava sofrendo
sozinha o que acontece com as crianças é
que elas não têm a capacidade racional
de explicar o que está acontecendo com
elas e muitas vezes elas não consegue
dizer não conseguem compartilhar às
vezes a gente nem com um nem a gente
adulta consegue fazer isso imagina as
crianças né
então é muito comum a gente ver as
crianças sofrendo sozinho
e eu comecei a perceber que esse
sofrimento estava vindo de um lugar de
cobrança todos os lugares que eu ia acho
que na sociedade ela é muito cruel né
porque ela cobra muito das crianças para
serem melhores pelas então eu estava me
sentindo muito cobrada pra falar mais
baixo e ser menos muleka pra não correr
tanto para tirar notas melhores para ser
mais educada e a minha leitura de
criança quando eu via tudo isso
acontecer é que me ama como eu sou como
é que me ama que é quem me ama é
imperfeita do jeito que eu do que eu sou
que eu sou né
e é o meu só olhos de criança eles não
conseguiam achar essa resposta
e aí eu cheguei no lugar onde de repente
veio uma pessoa uma um insight neve uma
percepção de que aqueles sentimentos
todos que eu estava tendo em relação aos
meus alunos aos meus competidores entre
aspas
eles vinham dessa criança interna ferida
que tinha é que olhavam lugar do outro e
não conseguia reconhecer e não conseguia
cerebral lugar de sucesso do outro
porque ela própria não tinha sido vista
não tinha sido reconhecida na sua
essência a criança interno chama do
nosso lado é que guarda nossas memórias
nossas memórias boas nossas memórias
ruins é o nosso lado que quer evoluir
ele precisa de cuidado ele precisa de
atenção e precisa de carinho porque
senão ele não consegue pra frente e ele
fica gritando por atenção até a gente
resolver ter paciência para olhar o que
está acontecendo
quando essa percepção eu parei e fiquei
quieta deixando aqui vou sentar no meu
coração eu senti uma calma vindo e aí eu
entendi que na verdade essa calma ela
vinha dessa minha criança que ela tinha
sido vista então ela estava acamada ela
parou de utilizar e aí eu percebi o
quanto essa essa experiência tinha sido
impactante e profunda quando dias depois
eu de novo me deparei com algum aluno um
sucesso com um trabalho maravilhoso e eu
estava tranquila toda calma
tudo bem nas relações profissionais
acontece a mesma coisa que nossas
relações pessoais
a gente pode olhar para o outro
independente se ele está sendo certo e
errado tá falando besteira eu sei lá o
que a gente tem oportunidade de entender
aquela relação como se fosse um espelho
onde a gente olha pra nós mesmos ea
gente pode começar a puxar essa
investigação que dá pra gente presentes
essa investigação traz pra gente um
processo profundo de desenvolvimento
pessoal onde a gente consegue amadurecer
e onde conseguem se libertar de ganhar
liberdade quando a gente entra nesse
lugar mais profundo e aí eu fico
pensando e os grupos que também é uma
coisa que eu peço muita atenção é quando
está trabalhando num grupo numa empresa
ou senão uma ong enfim por uma causa e
aparece outro grupo trabalhando pela
mesma causa
a gente pensa pode poderia ser tão legal
né que ótimo que essa galera também
chegou são aliados vindo aqui me ajudar
a trabalhar por essa causa nosso público
eles vão ser melhor atendidos porque tem
mais gente trabalhando por isso
só que nem sempre é assim a gente olha
daqueles grupo para aquele grupo novo e
pensa assim a vida trabalhando na mesma
área é a mudança de metodologia bem
melhor vídeo que atua aí você não vai
muito longe não né gente pensa isso
internamente
e aí é esse momento em que eu acho que
eu vejo assim que pode ser bom parar
tudo começar a puxar a cordinha vermelha
porque na ponta provavelmente vocês vão
achar uma criança que está precisando de
atenção que está precisando de um olhar
mais cuidadoso quando a gente não puxa a
corda vermelha ea gente deixa nossa
criança interna ferida atuar por nós e
se relacionar por nós
a gente se relaciona a gente não
consegue com existia como se não pudesse
ter eu e outro ao mesmo tempo começa a
criar muros começa a criar defesas
porque no fundo o que está dentro de mim
fala quem está dentro de mim falando a
minha criança que pode estar com medo
de ser julgada pode estar com medo de
perder o seu lugar
eu acho que cada pessoa tem uma história
e cada criança tenha sua vivência tem
suas memórias e tem a sua forma que ela
precisa ser cuidado
a nossa dimensão pessoal ela tem um
impacto gigante no coletivo
se a gente deixa nossas crianças
internas feridas agirem por nós a
tendência é a gente viver num mundo
muito mais difícil a gente cria muita
dificuldade a gente cria um mundo mais
recente du mas defendido mas separado
eu sei que a minha criança interna
tatuando quando eu dou aquela gelada na
pessoa que não me deu atenção na hora
que eu queria
e aí nessa hora eu pego falou calma
deixa eu
calma minha linha vem aqui eu sei que
está triste você não teve atenção está
tudo bem eu acolho a minha milla madura
eu vou lá e tento resolver de uma forma
mais tranquila a situação e aí você deve
estar perguntando será que eu tenho está
com a criança madura quase iluminada
curada para então eu poder começar a
trabalhar no coletivo e poder colaborar
de outra forma
a minha resposta não a gente pode sim
trabalhar com o coletivo mesmo tendo com
o nosso processo individual em andamento
a gente pode ter a criança madura
a gente pode ser nossa criança a nossa
criança interna ferida precisa de
atenção e ao mesmo tempo nosso adulto
cuidando a gente pode porque a gente tem
essa capacidade é possível sentir
tristeza e felicidade ao mesmo tempo
você já sentiram tristeza sessão triste
por algum motivo da viagem acontece
alguma coisa legal vem alguém que você
gosta muito de dar um abraço vida tão
feliz mas continua triste né você
a gente tem essa capacidade de ter
vários sentimentos ao mesmo tempo a
gente não é a gente não é uma coisa ou
outra a gente pode sentir ciúmes mas ao
mesmo tempo sermos generosos para a
gente poder abrir espaço para pessoas
que estão trabalhando na mesma área que
a gente a gente tem a capacidade de além
do certo e do errado e colaborar com
pessoas e instituições que não são 100
por cem
ressoam antes ou que estão tão alinhados
com o que a gente acredita contudo que a
gente acredita a gente pode ir muito
além disso nós somos seres ilimitados
somos seres criativos e mesmo quando a
gente fala de dinheiro que a gente pode
talvez começar a ganhar menos dinheiro
da mesma forma como a gente sempre
ganhou
nós temos uma capacidade de criar forma
super inovadoras de poder fluir a
abundância de várias formas diferentes
nós somos capazes de sair desse conforto
do individual e colaborar com esse
criativo da e se passa por um coletivo
mais harmônico mais equilibrado e aí
nesse momento eu ganho presentes porque
se eu tô nesse lugar onde eu não me
sinto tão preparado mas mesmo assim o
espaço coletivo eu estou vibrando
coragem
estou vibrando generosidade e nessa hora
eu acredito que a nossa vibração ela se
eleva e aí a gente entra num fluxo o
coletivo ele devolve com o melhor que
ele pode devolver pra gente eu hoje
tenho vários colegas de área é e eu ter
algum cliente me chama eu preciso de uma
equipe de 10 pessoas eu posso chamar os
colegas
a gente toma cerveja a gente vai comer
pizza a gente discute sobre a área e eu
estou vivendo uma aventura hoje porque
eu tô empreendendo eu estou fazendo
novas histórias acontecerem seja como já
aconteceram com vocês em alguma época da
sua vida de ter muita sincronia sá onde
você sem entender muito de onde vêm
vocês começam a ter respostas pessoas
que estavam precisando que aparecessem
na sua vida e se chama de fluxo e o
fluxo acontece
ele acontece quando a gente consegue
levar nossa vibração
eu sinto que quando a gente consegue eu
seu simples se a gente conseguir juntos
todos nós juntos antes de dar um passo
em direção ao coletivo com coragem e
generosidade
a gente não tem ideia em
de onde que as abundância pode levar a
gente eu acho que ela vai ser uma coisa
a gente não tem nem idéia
obrigado
[Aplausos]